افادت مراسله الجزيره بان مقاومين
فلسطينيين اطلقوا النار على قوات الاحتلال
في بلده يعبد جنوب غرب جيني شمال الضفه
الغربيه وقد اندلع اشتباك مسلح بين
المقاومين وقوات الاحتلال تنضم الينا من
جنين مراسله الجزيره جواره البديري التي
تتابع لنا التطورات من هناك اهلا بك جواره
ما الذي
حدث قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في هذه
الاثناء عبد السلام تقوم باقتحام عدد من
المنازل اي هناك عدد منها تعرض للتخريب
والعبث في المحتويات كما نشرت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عدد من جنود القناصه
على اسطح عدد من المباني
السكنيه العمليه تتركز في حارتين هما
السلمه وايضا الحاره الشماليه وسط بلده
يعبد الواقعه تحديدا جن جنوب غرب جنين
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اقتحمت القريه
باليات بزعم ان قوه راجله كانت قد دخلت
الى ال القريه من بضع جنود تم اطلاق النار
عليهم من قبل عدد من المقاومين
الفلسطينيين ف على الفور قامت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بتعزيز هذه القوه
باليات عسكريه دخلت ال البلده اقتحمتها من
تحديدا المدخل الجنوبي ومن منطقتين ولا
زالت العمليه متواصله هناك كان هناك ايضا
اعتداء على المصلين في احد المساجد فور
انتهاء صلاه المغرب حاول المصلون الخروج
بعد اداء الصلاه الا ان جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قاموا بتوجيه الاسلحه اتجاهم
ومنعوهم من ال خروج من المسجد ايضا في ذات
الشان اندلعت اشتباكات مسلحه بين مقاومين
فلسطينيين وجنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
البلده وقام ايضا عدد من المقاومين بالقاء
ما تعرف بالاكوا اي عدد من ال القنابل ال
الناسفه ولكنها محليه الصنع اتجاه جنود
الاحتلال ال اسرائيلي هذه البلده تتعرض كل
بضع ايام
للاقتحام ضمن نطاق محافظه جنين وراينا
بالامس اقتحام لقريه صير هناك توقعات لدى
الاهالي بان يكون هناك ايضا اقتحامات ل
قرى اخرى لم تكن اي اصلا عرضه لعمليات
الاقتحام ولكن لدى قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اي وفق الاهالي وما يتم ابلاغ
عدد من اهالي نشطاء وحتى طلبه جامعات بان
يقوم ابنائهم بتسليم انفسهم لكن بالطبع
الشبان لا يسلمون انفسهم وبالتالي لدى
الاهالي شعور بان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ستقوم مجددا با باقتحام قرى
اخرى وبالتالي يرتفع عدد حالات اعتقال منذ
السابع من اكتوبر الى اكثر من
5500 حاله قال في الضفه الغربيه اكثر من
326 شهيدا سقطوا منذ السابع من اكتوبر
ومنذ بدايه العام اي في اقل من اسبوع قتلت
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اكثر من سبعه
شبان فلسطينيين في انحاء متفرقه من الضفه
الغربيه جبار البديري مراسله الجزيره من
جنين شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه الايضاحات